[Music]
have you ever wondered what is the best
number of legs
I mean probably not but how many legs a
species has is vital to a life-form
success and it's time someone figured
out which number Reigns Supreme so for
this entry into the archive we'll
explore every option for leg count that
nature makes available excluding cases
of genetic mutation or limb loss whether
you're reincarnating soon or a World
Builder looking to improve the realism
of an alien life form this is a question
you need answered
we'll kick things off by discussing life
forms with one leg you might not think
any species has a single leg as their
default setting but nature doesn't care
what you think many clams and oysters
use a single muscular limb to drag
themselves along and their gastropod
relatives a group that includes snails
and slugs have a similarly bold approach
though it might not look like it the
bottom of one of these slimy fellows is
actually a single giant foot which they
slowly undulate to move forwards the
only way this even remotely works is
because the snails constantly lubricate
their undersides with mucus allowing
them to triumph over friction although
just barely as most species clock in at
a blazing one millimeter per second but
if your only method of locomotion was
coating your shoes in oil and shuffling
your feet you probably wouldn't get very
far either many species in this category
are herbivores as anything faster than a
leaf might outrun them perhaps on
another planet a life form could evolve
to hop along under one leg at greater
speeds although the laws of physics mean
that any single limb species will likely
struggle with uneven terrain still any
lineage that when coming onto land
looked at animals with multiple legs and
said I'm good thanks is pretty hardcore
up next we have two legs a unique option
with some major advantages and some
major disadvantages when it comes to
things like keeping your balance the
vast majority of two-legged species on
Earth evolved from four-legged ancestors
which means their former front limbs are
now free to be used for all kinds of
weird stuff birds are a massively
successful two-legged group whose
forelimbs evolved into Wings allowing
them to soar through the skies in a move
that feels kind of like cheating they
barely even use their legs it's not fair
not all birds take the easy route
however ostriches and other large
flightless birds strut about with us
land dwellers and Penguins well if they
don't strut exactly but they do their
best instead of wings penguin 4 limbs
have evolved into flippers increasing
their speed in the water but not so much
on land
But Wings and flippers aren't the only
option for what a two-legged animal does
with their front limbs primates have
evolved grabby hands they use in all
sorts of inventive ways like snagging
food swinging from branches and cleaning
their fur or the fur of others now it's
worth noting that not all primates are
completely loyal to team two legs great
apes for example often switch into a
semi-four-legged posture called knuckle
walking in fact lots of animals only
switch to two legs when it's trendy
Bears typically plot around on all fours
but will rear up on their hind legs to
climb trees or appear larger meerkat
switched two legs when scanning for
danger the added height giving these
nervous Lookouts a better View
but let's look at the true converts to
the two-legged Doctrine humans though
our stability isn't the best at first an
adult human sense of balance is on
another level with practice a human's
flexibility on two legs becomes kind of
ridiculous we might start off crawling
on our hands and feet and like primates
we can still move on all fours if we
want but it's nowhere near as fast as
switching to a two-legged stance and
running Full Tilt free from the burden
of supporting our bodies our front limbs
have become Advanced tools for
interacting with the world and for
showing other animals how cool we are
across media lots of aliens have bipedal
body plans mainly because lots of aliens
are actors in budget-friendly costumes
that's not to say two-legged life
couldn't emerge on other worlds they
just probably wouldn't look like us
in the end the two-leg setup is a strong
Contender for the top spot despite some
flaws like back pain
next we've got three legs and right away
there's a problem because no species has
three legs right well it's complicated
the tripod fish is a deep sea dweller
that perches on the sand using three
legs derived from elongated fins whether
or not these fins should be counted as
legs is debatable as is actually
trickier to Define what a leg is than
you might expect by most scientific
definitions a leg is any limb used
especially for supporting the body and
for walking strangely enough under this
definition kangaroos are another animal
sometimes placed in the three-leg
category because when they're not
hopping around their tails function as
third legs that keep them upright what
counts as a leg is a question that will
only get weirder as this video continues
but for now it's clear that three legs
aren't the most popular part of this may
have to do with the physics of walking
but it could also be because no early
land animals came under the water with
three Limbs and in an alternate history
Evolution might have taken a stranger
path
but for a species afraid of breaking the
mold four legs are a safe Choice when
you think land animals on planet Earth
this is probably the number of legs that
comes to mind as the default and for
good reason structurally a four leg
setup means stability the type of
stability that lets you grow into a kind
of living flagpole if evolutionary
pressures demand it four legs are also
great for off-roading letting animals
push through tough conditions they allow
for an ideal running gate and it's no
accident this category is home to the
fastest land mammals really four legs
are good for whatever but it's not just
mammals who have gotten in on the action
reptiles have had four legs since before
it was cool another four-legged species
are kangaroos wait kangaroos are here
too I mean they do walk on all fours
sometimes but seriously they move on two
legs three legs and four legs I'll allow
it I guess
the only real disadvantage to committing
all the way to four legs and no arms is
that picking things up becomes a real
challenge unless you're an elephant a
species which breaks all the rules by
turning their snoots into long muscular
appendages elephants probably look at
other species that had to choose between
being able to pick things up and getting
really big and just laugh an elephant's
trunk has over 40 000 muscles more than
in the entirety of the human body which
honestly feels like they're rubbing
things in a bit
overall four legs are a great basic
choice and likely would be no matter the
planet
five legs are far less popular the
category would be pretty Barren if it
weren't for a group of star-shaped
Oddities most species of starfish
possess five limbs that somewhat stretch
the definition of a leg as it's actually
the numerous tube-like feet below each
limb that allows a starfish to move
along the sea floor their bandages are
sometimes called legs sometimes called
arms and sometimes called Rays a third
unique category created specifically
because starfish refused to be normal
the other candidate for a five-legged
animal is the kangaroo kangaroos again I
guess they really do sometimes use all
five you know what no I don't care that
science backs them up on this kangaroos
are officially disqualified
moving on to six legs just kidding
there's another category we don't want
to keep waiting though easy to overlook
because they're close to the ground many
animals have no legs at all snakes are
probably the most famous group in this
category able to move by using their
muscles to push their scales against
terrain while this might sound like a
huge pain snakes and other legless
lizards gave up their appendages for
good reason as their limbless bodies are
perfectly adapted to slide into Burrows
in around tight Corners in search of
prey worms are also getting along just
fine without legs moving by Contracting
and relaxing the segments of their body
fish also technically qualify as legless
animals navigating The Aquatic realm
with fins alone except for Rebels like
the flying gurnard which walk along the
sea floor using modified pelvic fins in
submarine life-like anemones and coral
can spend their whole lives in a single
spot feeding on small aquatic organisms
and generally living more like plants
than animals many of these species could
be classified as sessile or fixed in one
place and should probably be in their
own bonus category it's easy to judge
but if you could hang out on a rock all
day and have food come to you would you
really be in a hurry to go anywhere
all right back to six legs for real this
time it's a category that might not
strike you as popular but is actually
the most widespread of all this is
because the majority of insects have six
legs and there are around 10 quintillion
insects on planet Earth scuttling along
often unnoticed by the large animals
they vastly outnumber six legs are
incredibly versatile enabling insects to
move while maintaining a supportive
tripod at all times some species also
evolved wings from ancient gill-like
appendages meaning they didn't even have
to trade in a pair of Limbs for flight
which seems massively unfair and with so
many limbs to spare some insects have
gotten pretty creative praying mantises
are a group that have turned their front
limbs into grasping appendages while
keeping their four back legs on the
ground a body plan that's basically as
close as life on Earth gets to a centaur
there's some inventive concepts of
intelligent aliens with similar Anatomy
which seems like a layout with great
theoretical potential well there are no
large six-legged animals on our planet
the unparalleled success of insects
suggests that such a body plan might
have serious advantages
the seven leg category has almost no
takers unless you count the seven arm
octopus which keeps one of its eight
tentacles used for fertilization
retracted in a sack beneath its right
eye seems a bit like cheating but I'll
let it slide
certain starfish also have seven legs
although once again that depends on your
definition you might have noticed that
there's lots of animals with an even
number of legs yet scarcely any with an
odd number this has to do with bilateral
symmetry the tendency of animals right
and left halves to be roughly mirror
images this trend is likely because a
bilaterally symmetrical species is
faster and more direct than a radially
symmetrical species like a starfish
whose lack of a distinct front or back
makes moving in a straight line a real
challenge the best chance for an
odd-legged organism to hit the big
leagues is probably if a radially
symmetrical life form later evolved
bilateral symmetry which seems to be the
origin of the seven limbed aliens in
arrival
back to even numbers eight legs are the
domain of insect's cool older siblings
the arachnids the poster children of
this group are spiders and tarantulas
most of whom have turned their eight
legs into all-terrain web climbing
machines some people find an arachnid's
legs Overkill but they might look at us
and think we're seriously under equipped
the other most famous eight-legged
Contender is the octopus who typically
possess eight multi-purpose tentacles
that can both carry them across the sea
floor and function as arms some have
argued that the octopus is technically a
biped as they'll sometimes use only two
tentacles to move across the sand this
depends on the species however and
there's a strong case to be made that an
octopus's tentacles meets the criteria
for both arms and legs proving that you
can't put an octopus in a box they'll
just ooze back out again
both octopuses and spiders have been
observed functioning just fine with
missing limbs because when you have
eight legs you've got enough despair
the nine leg category is another
unpopular odd number section with the
closest contenders being the nine raid
starfish or the exceedingly rare
nine-armed octopus although its extra
limb only happens when a severed
tentacle regrows as to
but with 10 legs things really get crazy
as we enter the domain of crustaceans
many species of lobster and shrimp have
a full 10 legs and with that many legs
available things can get weird crabs are
crustaceans that have gone the Centaur
root and lifted their front limbs off
the ground to use his Pinchers
some crabs have even turned their back
legs into flippers to uh swim because
when you have 10 limbs to work with you
might as well as we know the crab model
is a favorite of evolution as numerous
other Crustaceans have converted to the
way of the crab creating multiple false
crab lineages that jealously copy the
crabs winning formula
while more legs aren't always better the
stunning popularity of crustaceans
suggests that they're onto something
with their High limb count and that life
on other planets might just be a bunch
of crabs
Beyond The Event Horizon of 10 legs we
enter a black hole of ever increasing
digits giant deep sea isopods have a
staggering 14 legs caterpillars have a
rough average of 16 total legs with six
primary limbs in the front and multiple
rows of pseudo feet in the back to help
them move their elongated bodies
centipedes can have anywhere from 16 to
over a hundred legs and finally some
millipedes can have an even higher
number than that
in this species with the absolute
highest number of legs is the humilipes
Persephone which has an astonishing
1300 legs in total though an impressive
total count such a number is only needed
to help the species push through the
soil deep below the ground and would be
an absurdly impractical number for the
vast majority of life on Earth
so what's the answer well it depends and
yes I know that's not the most fun
answer but I promise it's the one that's
accurate there are some standouts but as
easy as it would be to arbitrarily
assign two legs or six legs or ten legs
as the winner you would be ignoring the
complexity of nature if there is one
thing we've learned though it's that
nature shows an astonishing amount of
variability when it comes to leg numbers
so should you ever design a life form
know that you have a lot of creative
freedom in terms of total limbs
in the end perhaps we should strive to
appreciate the leg counts of all animals
except for kangaroos
in speaking of numbers I'd like to thank
all my subscribers for bringing curious
archive past the 500 000 Milestone plus
a little extra that's over 498
000 more people than the humilipes has
legs which is absolutely astounding to
me I really can't express my gratitude
enough to every one of you this channel
wouldn't be possible without your
continued support thank you all so much
for watching
and if you're new to the channel this is
the part where I say if you enjoyed this
entry you can lend your support by
liking subscribing and hitting the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious
see you in the next video